Kamala Harris traded her disingenuous
cackle for a disingenuous shriek over
the weekend when she attacked Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis over his State's
new curriculum which she insists praises
the benefits of slavery
this is unnecessary to debate whether
enslaved people benefited from slavery
are you kidding me
are we supposed to debate that
[Applause]
let us not be distracted
by what they're trying to do which is to
create
unnecessary debates to divide our
country
now of course that is not what the
curriculum States we've got the text
that the new Florida standards State
quote instructional materials shall
include the vital contributions of
African Americans to build and
strengthen American society and
celebrate the inspirational stories of
African Americans who prospered
even in the most difficult circumstances
these supposedly controversial section
that Kamala was referring to Simply
acknowledges that quote slaves developed
skills which in some instances could be
applied for their personal benefit
which is obviously true this is the
thesis of Booker T Washington's book Up
From Slavery this is the premise of much
of Frederick douglass's writing this is
what was going through the mind of the
black black historian William B Allen
when he wrote the supposedly racist
offensive standards
what's more important than that
dishonest purpose is the truth and this
curriculum is devoted to telling the
truth whereas Kamala Harris has retailed
a lie now it may only have been a
falsehood the first time she stated it
but when you repeat a falsehood it
becomes a lie this curriculum is about
is having people who live The Experience
who live the history tell their stories
and nothing is more important than that
we never ever erase the stories that the
people who live the stories tell no one
has a right to interpret before first
understanding the stories as the people
who lived them understood them
themselves
the biggest problem with kamala's attack
is not the dishonesty that's par for the
course the problem is the claim that
she's attacking is true
it's a deep and enduring truth slaves
benefited from enduring hardship just as
everyone can benefit from enduring
hardship and the fashionable insistence
that suffering is always bad is making
us a nation that is weak confused and
depressed because we can't make sense of
human nature and the fact of a Fallen
World on that chipper note I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with code Knowles
kwles go to goodranchors.com use code
Knowles today
Republican Congress lady Nancy mace made
a joke about fornicating at the National
Prayer Breakfast it's caused quite a
stir and
most reactions I've seen to it are wrong
so we'll get to that in just a little
bit first though speaking of historical
revision a new gay historical figure
just dropped you know this happens every
every few years now the libs will take
some well-known historical figure and
then just decide out of the blue that
he's a gay guy or a lesbian or some
other kind of marginalized identity that
we all know he isn't so the the new the
new historical figure that the libs are
trying to Rainbow wash they're trying to
paint him Lavender is the poet Alfred
Lord Tennyson
and you might know Alfred Lord Tennyson
even if you're not a big poetry buff you
might know him because one of his poems
crossing the bar is frequently read at
funerals Sunset and evening star and one
clear call for me and may there be no
moaning of the bar when I put out to see
you may have heard that one a wonderful
poet I've always really liked Tennyson
and never suspected that he was a gay
guy and the reason I never suspected
that is that he was married for over 40
years and had two children and uh
another reason I never suspected that is
that there's no evidence whatsoever that
he is a little light in the old loafers
so
where do they get this from
this is the saddest part of the story
for me this is the saddest part of the
modern impulse to queer historical
figures
the evidence that this LGBT group it's
called the LGBT Heritage Trail in the UK
the evidence
that they say they have that Tennyson is
a gay guy is that
she had a friend
their evidence is that
Tennyson had this friend Arthur Henry
Hallam and he wrote a very famous poem
to him it's called in memoriam ahh and
it's where we get that line better to
have loved and lost than never to have
loved at all
Hallam
there is no evidence whatsoever that
Hallam had a romantic relationship with
Tennyson or the Tennyson desired
romantic relationship with Hallam or
anything like that they were college
buddies they were in a debating Society
together they were good friends they
traveled together they corresponded
quite a lot they obviously had a deep
love the love of friendship for one
another
but not only did they not have any
romantic love
Hallam was engaged to Tennyson's sister
so Helen would have been his
brother-in-law
and and the the reason that
I think the the libs maybe sincerely
maybe earnestly believe that these older
historical figures were gay is because
they don't understand friendship because
men are not really allowed to have
friends anymore modern culture is just
shocked
absolutely bewildered by the suggestion
that a man can have a deep friendship
because inasmuch as men are permitted to
have friends in modern society the only
kind of friends men are allowed to have
is the sort of uh go out and get
hammered or come over and watch the game
kind of friend that's fine but the
moment that a man has a friend with whom
he discusses things that really matter
with whom he uh talks about eternal
questions in whom he confides with whom
he has an actual friendship you know and
the old kind of Aristotelian sense of a
deep friendship a friendship of Truth
and virtue but then he's got to be a gay
guy because we just can't fathom that
you know we're in a very lonely Society
in a very alienated Society where
self-reported rates of loneliness and
depression and alienation have just
skyrocketed in recent years this is one
of the reasons why I'm not saying that
no historical figures were a little bit
queer someone like Walt Whitman was
probably a little light in the moccasins
but when you go to someone like Tennyson
and there's just no evidence of it
whatsoever other than the fact that he
had a friend that is an indictment of
our society and I think it lies at the
heart of a lot of the sexual confusion
and a lot of the political dysfunction
the fact that people don't have true
friends anymore we have friends of
convenience we have friends of work
friends by accident you know you work
with someone and maybe you go get a
drink with them afterward you have
friends of shared interests like you
both like Spider-Man or something so you
connect over that but proper friendship
you know friendship of the good
hard to find especially in a society
that's so relativistic and liberal that
we deny the very existence of the good
and so now we look back and we take
really good strong traditional
conservative poets and say that they
were
little a little bit eccentric I don't
think so I don't think so man when you
want to be sure of something
none of this confusion when you want to
be sure of something
like a good dinner you got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
you know that I love anything made with
top of the line quality for meat that's
good ranchers the only thing missing
is a pork box okay I've said it for a
long time well if you ask for it they
deliver good ranchers has just launched
their Prime pork 100 American pork that
is Steakhouse quality this new pork box
comes with bone in which is my favorite
and boneless pork chops sausage smoked
brats and more plus right now you will
get 30 bucks off with code Knowles at
goodranchers.com on their site you can
explore their All-American cuts of prime
pork prime beef better than organic
chicken options if you've tried their
beef and chicken before you know how
amazing it is I have said this for a
long time I fear that I haven't conveyed
it there is no service on the market
that gets you anywhere near the quality
of good ranchers and good ranchers has
the most competitive prices around it's
one of the few things I missed when I
was in Hungary head on over right now go
to goodranches.com use code knows 30
bucks off any box that is promo code
Knowles kwles goodranchers.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
speaking of
sexual confusion Nancy mace Republican
Congress lady
she's a liberal Republican but
I kind of like her she's she's been on
the right side of at least a handful of
issues and
she's clearly a little bit lost and
trying to figure things out and that's
true of a lot of people in modern
culture well Nancy mace really stepped
in it because she showed up to the
National Prayer Breakfast and decided to
open her remarks with a joke about how
she almost fornicated before showing up
to the event
another year another standing room only
event
and I woke up this morning at seven I
was getting picked up at 7 45. Patrick
my fiance tried to pull me by my waist
over this morning in bed and I was like
no baby we don't got time for that this
morning uh I gotta get to the prayer
breakfast and I gotta be on time and a
little TMI but um I you know he can wait
he's got we got I'll see him later
tonight
um but I was here early today
it's just so cringe and this is the
defining feature of Nancy mace's
political persona
and it's it's very sad and she should
try to nip it in the bud and a lot of
other conservatives who are who are
tempted this way should nip it in the
bud too
it's not the sex stuff it's that she
always wants to be
the cool conservative she's like the mom
on Mean Girls she want I'm not a regular
Mom I'm a cool mom
I'm not a regular conservative I'm a
cool conservative I'm not a regular
Christian you know I'm a cool Christian
I almost fornicated with a man who's not
my husband this morning but don't worry
I'm gonna do it later tonight anyway
let's talk about God In Prayer ah man
good grief lady
just read the room
read the room and
recognize that there are more important
things in life than being considered
cool by the liberals who hate you who
hate you no matter how
irreverent you are no matter how much
you try to distinguish yourself from
your political party and the
conservatives and your supporters they
will never like you
you're a republican okay your your best
option to be cool is to reject the
standards of coolness of the liberal
culture which
Which Way lies Madness and which will
always hate you and to be a conservative
and she says she's a Christian
but but here's how she says it she says
when she was defending these remarks she
said I go to church because I'm a sinner
not a saint glad those in attendance
including Senator Tim Scott and my
pastor her pastor was in attendance
how disgraceful for him that she would
do this
took this joke in stride but what was it
a joke it was a joke in that she
intended for it to be funny but I don't
think she's joking that she sleeps with
her fiance I think that part and maybe
she was joking about that and it was all
just a whole bit but I don't think it is
judging by her other comments because
Pastor Greg of course his name is Pastor
Greg Pastor Greg and I will have extra
to talk about on Sunday ha ha ha there's
a little laughing face emoji yes of
course we go to church
because we are sinners in this Fallen
World we're we're subject to
concupiscence and sin and death purvey
the world and you know it's a tough go
of it here and it's a pilgrimage and we
pray for grace of course there but for
the grace of God go I or all men sin and
fall short of the glory of God
you don't need to brag about it
because that will one suggest that
you're not really sorry for your sins
you haven't really repented you're just
brazenly
continuing in a state of grave mortal
sin which again describes a lot of the
world the difference is you're at least
putatively a Christian at a Christian
prayer breakfast
and and then furthermore you are
incurring the sin of Scandal because
you're leading others astray by saying
this is what Christians do and you're
you're implicating your pastor in that
sin also I I recognize it's a very
messed up culture and catechesis is
really weak these days and people don't
really know how they're supposed to
behave I have a great deal of sympathy
and empathy even for all of that but
this is a real indictment of this lady's
pastor of whatever ecclesial Community
Pastor Greg seems to be leading it
doesn't seem to be forming Souls all
that well if these are the kind of jokes
that his flock make at at National
Prayer breakfasts
and it raises the question why was she
invited to speak what
ah man what are these people going after
it's the conservatives and the the
nominal Christians in our culture what
are they going after do they do they do
they want to
establish a big tent and accommodate
themselves to the way of the world in
the way of the decadent degraded liberal
culture
to try to win some elections or fill up
the pews or something like that
or do they want to speak the truth and
speak the truth come what may because to
to win this some kind of nominal Victory
by adopting all of your opponents
beliefs and premises and behaviors is no
victory at all it's a puric victory it's
a concession it's a surrender it's a
loss
it's like that good old line which I'll
attribute to Fulton Sheen a few
different people lay claim to this line
if you marry yourself to the spirit of
the age you'll find yourself a widow in
the next
if you if you wedge yourself to the
spirit of liberalism as a conservative
then you haven't won anything you're
just you're just you're a big lip and
this is of course especially true in the
case if you're a Christian and you say
I'm a Christian but I just do all the
things that the world tell me to do and
I just try to seem cool by the standards
of this Fallen World which is under the
rule of of the Devil Himself then that's
not a victory man that's a loss then
what does it even mean to say you're a
Christian you know I was in Hungary last
week and I'll I'll publish the text of
my speech that I gave at the big
political conference there I'll publish
it on daily wire and I think there's
going to be a video that goes up soon
enough but the topic of my speech was
now salvation hinges on the flesh which
is a line from turtle and the early
Christian writer that the flesh itself
is the hinge of Salvation in modernity
we like to think that
my faith is just something that lives in
my head you know look maybe I sin all
the time and I lead others into sin and
I laugh about it and I brag about it and
I don't do anything to try to stop it
but hey if I think in my head that I'm a
Christian that I'm a Christian
even in the political Realm I can lit I
can move to a city I cannot get married
I cannot have kids I cannot take virtue
seriously I cannot go to church I cannot
do anything other than go to brunch and
live according to the modern liberal
culture but if I tell myself I'm a
conservative then I'm a conservative no
man you got to do it we live in time and
space we and especially when we're
talking about Christianity we're talking
about a religion that views the
Incarnation and the crucifixion and the
resurrection as the very pivot and
meaning of History it's the most
historically focused religion that there
is meaning time and space and actions of
real men in flesh and blood in places
Hungary gets this is which is why
Hungary has reordered its law and its
culture to better accommodate people who
are trying to pursue goodness and truth
and Beauty you see in the beauty of the
buildings that the the government is
actively trying to restore you see this
in the truth of the Eternal principles
that the government is enshrining in its
Constitution and its laws and you see
this in the clear moral vision that the
Hungarian government has laid out which
is nothing new it's just the traditional
moral vision of our Christian
civilization which the liberal societies
either ignore or invert and say that
good is evil and evil is good
that's you got to do stuff and let's say
that Nancy mace keeps sinning or
whatever you know we all sin at
different times but
we should be ashamed of that we should
not brag about it in public we should go
seek Absolution and forgiveness
speaking of Love marriage and the baby
carriage
some good news
Joe Biden is finally acknowledging his
granddaughter
you know I've haranged him on this show
for a long time because I say it's the
the worst thing that I could say about
Joe Biden forget about all the
corruption and the scandals and taking
money from the ukrainians and the lies
and all the rest of it
the meanest thing that I've ever seen
him do
is not acknowledged his sweet little
four-year-old granddaughter
and intentionally not acknowledge her
omit her stalking from the White House
Christmas display
constantly say I only have six grand
grandchildren not seven
finally though
uh Biden acknowledges her why is he
acknowledging her
in a statement
to People magazine Biden says
our son Hunter and Navy's mother London
are working together to foster a
relationship that is in the best
interests of their daughter preserving
their privacy as much as possible going
forward first of all that's not true
Hunter refuses to even speak to this
daughter Hunter just went to court to
try to stop paying the mother of Child
Support a hunter or to greatly reduce
the child support that he was paying
Hunter also just sued to stop the
daughter from having his last name in no
way there is zero evidence
that Hunter Biden is trying to establish
a relationship in the best interests of
the daughter Hunter is trying to
completely screw his daughter over and
and and mess her up and traumatize her
in every way possible that's all the
evidence that we have and Joe Biden's
complicit in that because it's not like
some private little spat between a a man
and his baby mama and a child born out
of wedlock and you say well it's private
life we're talking about the
granddaughter or the president of the
United States whether they want to or
not
this is a public matter that they have
to address the little girl is going to
know that her daddy that her granddaddy
rather is the president of the United
States and it's going to traumatize her
if her granddaddy is so ashamed of her
that he won't acknowledge her existence
and he's he's continued it that way for
four years now the girl's almost four
years old so anyway now he finally says
okay I'm going to acknowledge her good
on him good on him except he was only
bullied into it by a liberal columnist
at the New York Times Maureen Dowd wrote
this column that said the president's
cold shoulder and heart is counter to
every message he's sent for decades and
it's out of sync with the America he
wants to continue to lead very true so
he finally got bullied into it because
as we've seen in some other campaign
leagues this is becoming a big political
liability for him and so he dumps this
news on a Friday afternoon via written
statement I would not hold my breath
about him keeping up his promise he's a
dirty rotten liar that's been for his
old political career and he somehow made
a bad situation even worse in the
cynical way that he's tried to address a
a basic aspect of being a decent human
being
classic Joe Biden we got to restore some
balance to our relationships you got to
restore some balance to Nature into your
body that's why you got to go check out
balance of nature right now go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day through balance of Nature's
Advanced cold vacuum process the
vitamins minerals and phytonutrients of
the fruits and vegetables are preserved
so that you can get that vital nutrition
in each capsule balance of nature is a
whole food supplement with no additives
fillers extracts synthetics pesticides
or added sugar pure fruits and veggies
are the only things they put in their
capsules balance of nature sent a bunch
of their products down to the studio for
our team to try
we all love them when you're disciplined
enough to take care of your health you
reap all kinds of benefits your body
will thank you for a limited time this
summer when you become a preferred
customer balance of nature they're
throwing in a free fruits and veggies
travel set and giving an additional 25
bucks off your first order go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code
Knowles for a free travel set and 25
bucks off your first order as a
preferred customer that's
balanceofnature.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
speaking of the president
Joe Biden there's a new poll out from
Monmouth almost half of Republicans
think that Donald Trump is the strongest
candidate to take on Joe Biden
that does not mean that Trump is doing
really really well in the polls though
he obviously is this is a different
question
almost half of Republicans think that
Trump is the strongest candidate to take
on Biden the argument thus far for a
DeSantis or Nikki Haley or Tim Scott or
Mike Pence or Vivek ramaswamy even is
well look the base likes Trump but he
can't win the general
everyone knows he can't win the general
but but unfortunately the way the
primary process is set up though the far
right candidate sometimes can win the
primary and then will lose the general
because a more moderate candidate would
do better in the general now we covered
on the last show
moderate candidates as the GOP nominee
have a much worse track record than the
conservative GOP nominees for president
much worse go back to the last show I
won't I won't go through the litany
again but going back to Eisenhower after
Eisenhower you see a much stronger
showing from the conservative nominees
than from the John McCain's and the Mitt
Romney's but furthermore
this is now another knock on the
DeSantis campaign because the DeSantis
campaign can at least say look maybe
people don't feel as passionately about
me as they do about Donald Trump but
everyone knows I'm more likely to beat
Joe Biden than Trump is a poll like this
says no the the DeSantis campaign has
not convinced
Republicans of that
she got 45 percent of GOP voters few
trumpets definitely the best candidate
to beat Biden in addition 24 on top of
that say he is probably the strongest
candidate to defeat to face Biden so
this is
huge number
only 13 percent of Republicans said
definitely another candidate and only 18
said another candidate would probably be
stronger than Trump
so you add those numbers up all of a
sudden
you're at 69 say Trump is definitely or
probably the strongest candidate and you
get down here 31 percent
say that some other candidate is
definitely or probably the strongest
it's
it's something that the talking class
the punditarian the GOP establishment
but even even the conservative
establishment which very often lives in
Washington DC or New York or or even Los
Angeles and very often occupy Elite
circles uh just the nature of the
business uh they don't seem to recognize
very often Trump changes the calculus
it's not just a matter of policy
positions it's not just a matter of
going to ballotopedia and seeing where
the candidates stand on the issues he's
just a different kind of animal
he talks different he walks different
he's got a different background and he
appeals to different people and he he
turns off certain voters who the more
clubbable kind of Republicans sometimes
can impress but he also attracts
voters
that the more clubbable Republicans
haven't have never been able to impress
or haven't been able to impress since
Ronald Reagan
so what does this mean for the rest of
the field well the rest of the field is
going to keep on fighting including the
number two guy right now Ron DeSantis
who just came out to attack the clubable
Republicans
if you can't stand up for the protection
of children then what good are you as a
governor I mean honestly this is just
[Applause]
this is just nonsense these are like
these Chamber of Commerce Republicans
you know whatever the corporations want
they they bowed down to and that doesn't
work in a free Society it doesn't work
to have a just Society because Corporate
America unfortunately has become
polluted with ideology and they're
pursuing agendas and the sexualization
of children is wrong and we are going to
do battle with anybody that's seeking to
Rob our their children of their
innocence great line I love it I love
that DeSantis is going after the Chamber
of Commerce Republicans
it's a reminder that Ron DeSantis even
though now because he's running against
Trump he is attracting a number of
establishment people to support him
Ron DeSantis in his political Outlook
and promises and campaign platform is
much closer to Donald Trump
than he is to Mitt Romney or John McCain
or the bushes
or maybe even Ronald Reagan
Ron DeSantis is running
a populist anti-corporate anti-big
business campaign
this means
that all of the top GOP candidates right
now are running against the Chamber of
Commerce
a lot of the Gob candidates are running
while placating the Chamber of Commerce
Mike Pence most clearly said well look
we're we support business we don't want
to be against business when he was
attacking Ron DeSantis but Mike Pence
and basically all of the candidates
below Mike Pence in the polls they're
all running as the kind of pro-business
pro-chamber typical Country Club GOP
that you've seen
the top three candidates right now Trump
DeSantis and Vivek ramaswamy are all
actively explicitly running against the
Chamber of Commerce and big business
that is a major shift in the GOP in my
lifetime and that's a shift for the
better
because we're recognizing that there's
more more to life than just ticking up
the GDP numbers and a strong economy is
good but a strong economy is not the
be-all and end-all because if you make
that the absolute end of Politics as
many in the establishment and
libertarian Camp had done for the 90s
and the 2000s and into the 20 teens then
we're no different than the Mammon
worshiping materialists that we mock on
the left and that we're fighting against
that you want you want a good economy
that's a very valuable thing in society
but you don't want to put the cart
before the horse
you want the good economy in service of
a good country and if the corporations
are undermining the values and the
behaviors and the traditions and the
virtues of your country well then they
need to be brought into line
we need to recognize that the market
exists for us to have a good Society our
society does not exist to serve the
market now what about that third
candidate Vivek ramaswamy the vague is a
little different from Trump and DeSantis
in that Vivek is trying to cut a middle
ground between the new
more nationalist more populist
anti-corporate
Spirit of the GOP
obviously Vivek wrote a book called woke
Inc and his is regularly described as
the anti-woke businessman
so he's he's got that part going for him
but he's also trying to preserve some of
the classically liberal libertarian
Tendencies of the GOP in the last 10 to
30 years
so Vivek just came out and urged more
free trade and more legal migration
the cptpp I think we should re-enter it
I think this is a little bit different
than what you know the course of action
taken by Trump and exiting the TPP I
think that was actually maybe I think
that I can use the leverage of the fact
that we did exit it to be able to say
all right here's what we need done
differently in a number of the countries
from Japan on down to be able to say
here's how we re-enter that on fairer
terms and so that's what I'd like to see
that puts us in a strong position from a
trade perspective to then take a look at
where we stand visible China so I I
could go on for hours on this one so we
want to remain really Merit focused we
want to obviously um I think try to
attract the people from around the world
who are also Merit focused and wish to
join the country and we should make it
much easier for them to join I agree
with that I actually fully agree with
that and that's one of the things where
I think the Republican party needs to
Define where we actually stand there is
an anti-legal immigration current that
you know which is which which I'm going
to be on the debate stage in a month and
this is going to be something that if
anybody has any any qualms with this uh
you know I think I'm gonna have a real
problem with that because merit-based
immigration is one of the fixes to
economic growth in this country
so he's right about that last part
uh Mass migration Mass legal migration
has been in service of keeping the
economy afloat because people aren't
having kids anymore and that's true not
just in America it's true throughout the
west but that's still a problem
it's a problem because if you just flood
your country with foreigners and you
don't assimilate them as we haven't been
able to do in 50 years then you're going
to lose the things that that distinguish
your country also because there's more
to a country than just keeping the GDP
up though of of course you don't want
the economy to collapse but this is
this is an issue that probably won't
come up on the debate stage because none
of the candidates
as far as I can tell support a reduction
in legal migration they also we want to
end illegal immigration but we we want
we want a lot of legal immigration Trump
trump himself who's the most
anti-immigrant major candidate in my
lifetime he said we want more legal
immigration than ever and this is a
problem
one because I think it it
not only threatens the national identity
and cultural coherence and the the
notion that we're actually a country
defined by borders with a real citizenry
that's distinct from foreigners but
two because the majority of Americans
want to drastically reduce immigration
they don't usually say it in those terms
they won't say I'm anti-legal immigrant
if you just ask them that question do
you want more or less legal immigration
they'll often say more or keep it the
same but if you ask them what do you
think would be a good number for
migration
then you find out then there was a
famous Harvard Harris poll that came out
a few years ago on this point you find
out that people want drastically lower
immigration like 60 percent lower legal
and illegal because very often people
will say Well about half a million
people a year and that's nowhere near
what we've got we've got we've got
double that just in terms of legal
immigration and then this year alone
we're going to have over three and a
half million
people apprehended crossing the border
illegally
who knows what the real number is so now
you're talking about a huge huge number
uh
no candidate is speaking to that right
now I think if a candidate did say look
we it's nothing against foreigners it's
nothing against people from all sorts of
cultures but our culture is collapsing
and we have very little that unifies us
anymore including even the same language
we don't even really speak the same
language anymore we need as we have done
in American history a number of times we
need to drastically reduce all
immigration in order to regain some
sense of coherence and cohesion for our
people and then in 50 or 60 years maybe
we can open it back up a little bit
again what does this mean for the race
it means that Vivek is trying to cut
more of that classically liberal
view while still maintaining populist
and nationalist cred uh the migration
issue won't hurt him because nobody is
talking about reducing legal immigration
unfortunately uh the free trade issue
might because Trump has now come out and
said
I'm running on mercantilism for the 21st
century I'm running on protective
tariffs not merely as an instrument to
get good free trade deals but is it good
in and of themselves Ron DeSantis has
been a little unclear on this we don't
quite know exactly where he stands on
this issue of trade and now Vivek is
saying no I'm I'm still a free Trader
and and
maybe it's a smart move for Vivek in
that it allows him to distinguish
himself from the other top candidates in
the field and now we have to start
talking about Vivek who everybody said
oh I came out of nowhere no one knows
who he is he is now becoming a top
candidate in this field albeit in a
field that is dominated by one candidate
over all of the others but this is going
to be a test in 2024. how populist has
the GOP become how traditionally
conservative has the GOP become don't
forget the GP was founded on protective
tariffs conservatives traditionally have
been the pro tariff pro-protectionism
group of people in politics and the
Liberals have been the the free Traders
so that shifted a little bit at the end
of the 20th century this is going to be
a test
how conservative is this conservative
swinging of the pendulum really going to
be
now speaking of what corporations are
you sick of what corporations dragging
your values through the mud
wash your hands of it all with Jeremy's
brand new hand soap Jeremy's hand soap
is the perfect solution for everyday
grit and grime not to mention it smells
amazing as it is scented with green tea
and citrus not only is it paraben free
but it's also free of sulfates Dei and
ESG for that matter plus it's not tested
on animals and it's made right here in
the USA what more could you want from
your hand soap than to get clean hands
while keeping a clean conscience so do
yourself a favor and wash your hands of
hypocritical Libs once and for all
Jeremy's hand soap is the ideal addition
to your bathroom or kitchen sink as you
liberate your home of the influence of
woke companies go to jeremy'srazors.com
and order your green tea and citrus hand
soap today
my favorite comment on Fridays from
cheese Monk 3y127
who says I used to believe in aliens
until the government said they were real
great
observation
it's just so fake guys
aliens are angels and demons for
liberals that's all that's all it is
probably mostly just demons
that's what it is
that's what it is man
okay before we move on from 2024 just a
quick button here because there's
good news potentially good news for one
of the not top candidates
for Mike Pence
who's had a really rough launch to the
campaign who had a really rough town
hall with Tucker Carlson
at he may
have a glimmer of hope here to move back
up into the race and it is because Mike
Panzer of the weekend vowed
to reinstate the ban in the military
we can embrace our role as leader of the
Free World
confront Russian aggression and Chinese
provocations with a new military fitted
to the challenges in the 21st century
and we can end the political correctness
at the Pentagon including reinstituting
a ban on
Personnel in the United States military
there you have it
now
I think I'm allowed to keep this part of
the show on YouTube You Know YouTube
gets very touchy when I talk about
important social issues that are still
being debated right now you can talk
about issues that are not being debated
anymore that the libs already won but
you're not allowed to talk about ones
that are still hot so I I think we can
keep this part on YouTube because I'm
just observing
Pence's
candidacy Pence comes out and says I
want to reinstitute the ban in the
military
it reminds me that Pence's best
shot in this race
which probably won't work but I think
it's his best shot
is to be the hardcore social
conservative
Trump is not really a hardcore social
conservative practically speaking he's
more socially conservative than any
president in my lifetime and most other
GOP candidates maybe all of them but
he's a little open on the rainbow stuff
he's a little
ambiguous on some of those issues
he's a billionaire from New York what do
you expect
Pence has made his early career as a
hardcore social conservative
right now you don't totally see that
represented in the race as we just said
the vague is this great kind of Shake It
Up out of left field candidate
we've still got a little bit of that
Classical liberalism to him
uh DeSantis is pretty socially
conservative
but but still a really hardcore social
conservative could knock DeSantis for
the education bill in Florida saying
well hold on your education bill just
debated whether to introduce a
curriculum in third grade or fourth
grade what come on that's that's weak
stuff man now santis could come back and
say well don't worry we expanded that
later on and we've been practically more
effective on this issue than anyone else
in the country so he's got a good answer
for it but there's an opening there is
what I'm saying and the only opening I
see right now is
that one
what Pence staked his campaign on and
you saw it in the opening video and you
saw it in in a lot of his campaign since
then is I'm going to be the return to
normal I just want to get along with
business as usual and support
corporations and just be a nice normal
Republican kind of campaign completely
dead in the water man that's going
nowhere you're only your only light your
only chance here is to double out on
this kind of stuff so he might
have recognized that
and if he wants the campaign to remain
in any way viable I think he's got to
pursue that further
all right now for the part that I can't
keep on YouTube
hey yeah
[Music]
today is music Monday baby and it's
mailbag Monday a little bit of mailbag
because
on Friday back when I was still in
Hungary
I didn't get to as much in the mailbag
as I wanted there were a few questions I
didn't get to any of the written mailbox
questions so we're gonna get to a few of
them we're gonna get my iPad whenever
Professor Jacob gets me my iPad where is
it and we're gonna get to whatever the
song is today but only if you're a
member of the inner circle of this show
if you are ahoi paloi on YouTube then
you don't get it man I'm sorry you got
to go to dailywire.com right now use
code Knowles you'll get like a bazillion
months free or something I don't know
whatever the promo is now you go to
dailywire.com use promo code nulls
they're telling me we'll get two months
free on all annual plans and I will get
to chat with you momentarily
[Music]
thank you